دليل كامل ومفصل لمحاكمه ترامب ومحاوله
للاجابه على سؤال المليون حينفع يصير رئيس
لو تمت ادانته وظهور سبب احتجاز مسي ساعات
في بكين مو عارف الفرق بين تايوان والصين
ومفاجاه مدويه جديده في حادثه قرش الغردقه
ادعاءات بانه اكل اثنين قبل الروسي اهلا
بكم
[موسيقى]
طيب الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
خرج امس من جلسه الاستدعاء للمحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي من دون قيد ولا كفاله
ترامب يواجه 37 تهمه جنائيه بخصوص احتفاضه
بوثائق وسجلات حكوميه وعسكريه من فتره
رئاسته اخذها معاه بعد ما انتهت ولايته في
20 21
السلطات لقيت الوثائق في منزل ترامب في
فلوريدا وبتقول انه هذا غير قانوني وهو
بيقول انه حق مطلق انه ياخذها وعنده هو
تبريراته للموضوع قبل ما هذا كله يصير
ترامب كان قال انه الوثائق مو معاه وبعدين
رفض انه يرجعها وقت طلبوها منه رسميا
واتهموا بالتامر لعرقله عمل المحققين اللي
كانوا بيسعوا لاستعاده الوثائق بعدين
سلمها
المهم امس استدعي ترامب للمحكمه وراح
وبنذكر انه هذه المره الاولى اللي بتوجه
فيها تهم جنائيه من قبل محكمه سيدراليه
الى رئيس سابق نيجي لتفاصيل الجلسه واللي
حابين اليوم نمشي معكم فيها خطوه بخطوه
ونحاول نجيب على كل الاسئله المتعلقه فيها
خصوصا انه فيها تداعيات خاصه لليمون كثير
بالنظام القضائي الامريكي واسلوبه واحنا
اليوم معانا خبير في الحلقه حيجاوبنا على
اسئلتنا طيب نرجع للقصه الجلسه دامت 47
دقيقه عنوانها الولايات المتحده ضد دونال
لما دخل المحكمه كتار قالوا كذا صار قيد
الاعتقال وحتى الناس قالوا انه قانونا
يعتبر سلم نفسه لكن عموما لمن دخل ما حطوا
له كلبشات وما اتخذت له صوره المتهمين
اللي هي معروفه بالمقشط وفي كلام متضارب
عن موضوع البصمات لو الدي ان ايه لو
تاخدوا ولا لا مثل ما دائما بيحصل مع كل
المتهمين طيب احنا معانا من عمان المحامي
المزاول في نيويورك محمد تيسير النعيمي
اهلا فيك معنا محمد طيب خلينا اول شيء
نبتدي من قصه انه
دونالد ترامب vs do you
ضد الدوله ايش يعني هذا الموضوع
اهلا ست ساره يسعد مساكي ومسائل مشاهدين
الكرام مثل ما تفضلتي ببدايه عن القضيه هي
اسم القضيه كاسم هي بيانات امريكا ضد
متهمين اثنين احدهم دونالد ترامب تاتي
التسميه انه الخصم في هذه القضيه عند
قراءه اسماء اطراف الدعوه هي المملكه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كونه من يملك
حق تقديم وبدء القضايا الجزائيه بمعنى
القضايا اللي فيها جرائم هي ذراع التنفيذي
للولايات المتحده الامريكيه وهي الحكومه
فمن هذا فمن هذا المنطلق
بتكون السلطه لدى النائب العام للولايات
المتحده وما يعادله هو وزير العدل في
البلدان العربيه النائب العام هو بعطي هذه
الصلاحيات لمن يمثلوه دوائر الادعاء العام
والنيابه العامه وفي مثل هذه الجرائم
الجرائم الجزائيه القضايا الجزائيه اللي
ما فيها حق ما بين شخص ين اثنين قرار
جزائيه بتكون هي الحكومه من هي الخصم
وبكون هو الادعاء العام اللي هو اصلا
بترافع بهذه القضيه وهو عليه عاتق اثبات
انه المشتكى عليه في مثل قضيتنا دونالد
ترامب هو مذنب وهو ارتكب هايل هاي الجريمه
لما بنقول انه هو رهن الاعتقال وسلم نفسه
هذه اوصاف دقيقه
يعني مو دقيقه مئه بالمئه لانه يعتمد على
الانطباع اللي عند الناس احنا اذا بنحكي
هو رهن الاعتقال معناه هو مقيد او في مكان
لا يمكن الخروج منه ولكن هو طوع نفسه
وامتفل امام المحكمه وقبل بولايتها عليه
بحيث انه كانت حريته اللي اعطاها الدستور
مقيده يعني ما بقدر يطلع من المحكمه لازم
يمتثل للاوامر اللي بتحكي له اياها
المحكمه لازم يمثل امام المحكمه
تساله اسئله يجاوب عليها فمنقدر نحكي انه
حريته كانت مقيده نوع هذا التقييد عام
احنا منسميه ارست يعني هو زي رهن الاعتقال
ولكن باخذ اكثر من شكل بحالتنا ما كان
معتقل مقيد وداخل زنزانه او الى ما ذلك
المرحله اللي جات يعني بعد هذه يا محمد
انه ترامب دخل خلاص وبدات الجلسه وفيها
انقرا لائحه الاتهامات اللي ضده واللي
مكونه من 44 صفحه بعدين اقر بانه غير مذنب
في التقاضي الامريكي في معروف انه في شيء
اسمه الاقرار بالذنب او قلت هذا بلي وانه
المتهم في اول المراحل بيقول هو شايف نفسه
مذنب او لا خلينا نسالك اكثر ونفهم هذه
جزئيه يا محمد ايش بتعني انه قال نط قلتي
او غير مذنب وايش بيترتب عليها
نعم 60 مثل ما تفضلتي تبدا اجراءات
المحاكمه المتعلقه بالجزاء لما يكون في
جرائم اول جلسه بتكون يحضر المشتكى عليه
او المتهم وبساله بساله قاضي مو شرط يكون
نفس القاده راح ينظر القضيه اول اشي
بشرحلو ايش هي التهم المسنده اليه بتاكد
اذا كان تبليغه صحيح بخصوص التهم وثالثا
هو القلت بلي بساله هل انت مذنب ام غير
مذنب وهذا السؤال مصير جدا لانه احنا زي
ما بنعرف اذا عمل فهو اعترف والاعتراف سيد
الادله ففي حال اذا قال هو مذنب يفقد حقه
يضمن له اياه الدستور الامريكي بالتعديل
رقم سته وهو انه لا يجوز لا يجوز حكم على
شخص الا عن طريق محاكمه ويكون في ادوار
تبادل اللوائح ويكون هاي اذا قال هو مذنب
فقد هذا الحق وتنتقل الان المحكمه الى
تحديد موعد للجلسه لاصدار الحكم بالعاده
او يعني اتفاق ما بين بكون بين الشرطه او
الادعاء العام او مثلا
بتتفاوض مع المشتكى عليه بتحكي له اذا انت
بتذنب وبتوفر علينا عناء سنوات من القضاء
وسنوات من الشهود والخبره ممكن يفوز ممكن
يخسر اذا بتنذب احنا بنقدر نعمل لك
تخفيف للعقوبه ولهم هذا الحق انهم يخففوا
العدو اذا كان في اتفاق بيسمى
اذا ما كان في اتفاق بالعاده بقول مذنب او
غير مذنب اذا حكم مذنب انتهت الاجراءات
بصير في تحقيق موعد اصدار الحكم بعد ما
ترم قال انه غير مذنب يعني صار في نقاش
مطول بين محامين وبين الادعاء والقاضي حول
قيود معينه عليها خلال فتره المحاكمه
بعدها افرج عنه بتعهد شخصي ومن غير كفاله
وحتى نساعد الادعاء لو يبغى يتحفظ على
جواز سفر ترامب قالوا لا كيف نفسر محمد
سبب الافراج من غير كفاله وليه ما طالبوا
مثلا بج واز سفره
نعم الستي هي هاي من الاجراءات المؤقته
اللي يا بطلب فيها الادعاء العام او
المحكمه بتظهرها من من تلقاء نفسها اذا
كان عندها شكوك او بقدر العام يبين
بالبينات انه هذا الشخص اذا اطلقنا صراحه
اليوم حيشكل خطر على المجتمع ممكن يرجع
يرتكب جرائم مره اخرى والاهم من ذلك انه
انا لازم اضمن حق اتاكد كدوله وحكومه ان
المشتكي عليه سيقوم بحضور كل الجلسات
المطلوب منها حضورها وما راح يغادر البلاد
الان التحليل اللي انا نظرا لانه الان
القضيه منظوره امام قاضي جوا اول درجات
القضاء الامريكي في الشرق الجزائي وهو
مهمته تقريبا انتهت فاذا اذا قدم مثل هذه
الحظ مثل هذه الاجراءات التحفظيه هذه
الاجراءات الحافظيه يجوز انه الاستئنافه
يعني نقدر نعترض عليها لحالها غير القضيه
فهو نظرا لانه السكوب
العمل تاعه الان اشي وهو ما حب يخلق اي اي
اي اشياء ممكن تؤثر القضيه للامام
بالاضافه بالاضافه الا انه دونالد ترامب
شخص اعلن نيته الترشح للانتخابات يعني راح
يضلوا بالولايات المتحده وثانيا هو شخص
معروف هو شخص معروف جدا ومن السهل التعرف
على اقامه
في هذا الموضوع وبعدين هو كمان طبعا اي
شيء يقولوا في هذه القصه حتكون بتخليه يا
منحاز للترميه يا منحاز للترمب وسيتم
تحويل على سياسيه لكن زي ما انت ذكرت يعني
محمد انه في نهايه الجلسه هذه القاضي فعلا
تنفس الصعداء ومزح وقال انه انا سعيد جدا
انه دوري انتهى في القضيه والمراحل الجايه
حتكون مع قاضيه ثانيه طيب اذا تقول لنا بس
انه ليش في قضيه ثانيه حتكون في المرحله
الجايه وايش المنتظر في الجلسه هذه اللي
جايه
نعم سيدتي مثل ما تفضلتي بمقدمتك هاي اول
قضيه ضد ضد رئيس ولايه المتحده اسبق في
المحاكم الفيدراليه يعني على مستوى على
مستوى اتحادي وقوانينها تطبق على كامل
ولايات اللي يشكلوا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه بالعاده اول اجراءات وهي
شرحناها الامتثال للمحكمه واخذ الصوره
والبصمات والسؤال المتهم اذا كان مذنب او
لا بالعاده تقوم فيها المحكمه المركزيه في
نفس المقاطعه بعد هذا الاجراء تحول القضيه
الى قاضي مختص في حالات بكون بتحول
بالقرعه بنظام الكتروني في حالات بتكون
صلاحيات رئيس المحكمه بحول القضيه عند
القاضي المختص الان القاضي المختص راح
تبلش اجراءات المحكمه وهو لانه قال انا
غير مذنب بلشنا اجراءات المحكمه ببلش
الادعاء العام اللي هو الخصم في هذه
القضيه في امريكا ببلش بتقديم
البينات تعونه
والادله اللي تعاونه وبعدين ببلش بالشهود
تعونه بس تخلص فتره الادعاء العام بتبلش
فتره الدفاع وهي فتره ترامبول المحامين
تاعه بيقدموا ادلتهم بيقدموا دفوعهم
يستجيبوا بهم هم الشهود وطبعا احنا بنعرف
هاي القضيه فيها جوري فيها هيئه محلفين
جراند جوري فيها هيئه محلفين حيكون مكونه
من عدد كبير فالمحكمه هذيك راح تشرع بكامل
اجراءات القضيه نسمع كل الادله
الدراما الحقيقيه يعني حنعيش الاجواء
الدراميه طيب محمد احنا مكملين معك
موضوعنا الرئيسي في الحلقه لكن بعد الفاصل
فخليك معانا مشاهدينا طبعا احنا فاصل
ونعود
اهلا من جديد الجزء الثاني من متابعتنا
لمحاكمه ترامب بيتعلق باللي صار بعد
الجلسه واللي حيصير عموما في المستقبل
ترامب خلال الجلسه كان ساكت ولا قال ولا
كلمه الا وقت مجال لكن بعد ما طلع من
المحكمه ما وقفت تصريحات اولها على باب
المحكمه وهو خارج لمن قال لان صاروا كله
تمام لا تقلقوا وبعدها راح مع مجموعه من
انصاره لاحد مطاعم ميامي احتفل بعيد
ميلاده 77 اللي صادف امس وكمان وجه كلمه
لهم من هناك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كان الوضع داخل المطعم بس على فكره مختلف
كثير عن خارج المطعم كمان كمان كان في
انصار ومتجمعين وبهنوا بعيد ميلاده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وبعد ما خلص الاحتفالات والاكل وكله راح
على النادي الجولف الخاص فيه وهناك عاد
كان الخطاب الرسمي الانصاري واللي وصف فيه
اللي صار بانه اشنع واكثر شر صار في
امريكا او في تاريخ امريكا قانونيه
[موسيقى]
كمان بهذا الكلام بل وسط بايدن بالرئيس
الفاسد وانه هاجم اكبر خصومه السياسيين
طبعا بيبصد نفسه
يوسف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مدعي عام خاص الى حقهم واكد ثقته بانه هو
يراجع رئيس الامريكا وحيرجعها عظيمه ثانيه
طيب خلينا نرجع لك محمد يعني ايش فرص
ترامب انه يصير رئيس وهو متهم في قضيه من
هذا النوع او لو فرضنا مثلا تمت ادانته
فعلا هل ممكن يترشح هو مدان او مسجون مثلا
نتكلم قانونيا يعني
قانونيا سته فيما يتعلق بالاتهام المتهم
بريء حتى ثبت ادانته فما دام اجراءات
المحاكمه هي مستمره هو بريء
في حال ادانته او في حال انه انحكم وانحبس
يعني هذا الموضوع
انشائك وفيه عده اراء قانونيه لانه
القوانين التي تمنع او تعطي هذا الحق ما
عمره صار عليها رئيس سابق للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واجه مثل هذه
الجرائم القانون الامريكي بالدستور
الامريكي لا يوجد اي منع على الترشز على
الترشح انما يوجد هناك ثلاث شروط اهمها ان
يكون عمر مترشح 35 سنه ان يكون اخذ
الجنسيه
وان يكون اخذ الجنسيه الامريكيه عن طريق
الولاده وان يكون عاش في امريكا لمده 14
سنه الان
هل يمنع ترامب بده في سيناريوهات قانونيه
اذا استمرت القضيه ترشح بعشرين اربعه
وعشرين وتمكن من الفوز الان يمثل السلطه
التنفيذيه اللي هي دونايتد الخصم في هذه
القضيه وهو وهو جزء من الادعاء العام وهو
يعين رئيسه ويقيله فهو يملك الصلاحيه انه
يخلي ادعاء العام يسقط هذا يسقط هذه يسقط
هذه القضيه في في حال تطورت القضيه لانه
يمكن ان يعني يمكن ان يزجل المشتكى عليه
بالسجن خلال مراحل القضيه ممكن القاضي
يامر بمرحله متقدمه انه يروح للسجن صارت
هذه الحاله في التاريخ الامريكي وترشح احد
الرؤساء الامريكيين وهو داخل السجن لا
يوجد ما يمنع ذلك ولكن لم يحالف في الحظ
بالفوز هلا اذا كان داخل السجن مع انه
هنالك موانع قانونيه كبيره تمنع اصلا ذهاب
اي رئيس الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه سابق الى السجن في حال
كان داخل وفي حال كان مدان هو يملك الحق
انه يقدم اعفاءات على على اي شخص على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه فهو قادر انه
يعفي انه في نفسه
فبالمحصله قانونا لا يوجد
في كل الاحوال ودين او ماؤدين كان داخل
القضيه او كانت لازالت القضيه ماشيه او
لسه ما هي ماشيه وفاز اموره تمام تمام من
دون ما نذهب محكمه تحدد هل يسمح القانون
لا يسمح لي انه هو عندما يكون لو مخلينا
نقول انه لا لسه ما كان فاز وانحكم عليه
انه يروح السجن انت بتقول في صعوبه انه
يدخل رئيس امريكي سابق السجن يعني انا
بوجهه نظري شبه مستحيل انه ينسى رئيس
امريكي الى يوم واحد لانه في قانون اللي
بقفل الحق للسوبر فيجن الاشراف والحمايه
وهي الامن القومي تاع الرئيس السابق وما
بيقدروا هاي الجهات المعنيه الامنيه انها
تعطي هاي صلاحيات للسجن ويصيروا هم السجن
مكلفين في في هذه الحاله ممكن لانه ما
عمرها صارت هذا القضيه ممكن يكون توصل اذا
توصل لاعلى محكمه بامريكا
ممكن انها تحكم انه يعني نقدر نحكم هو
ببيته ولكن بغض النظر ايش عم بحكي هو في
حال فوزه ايش القانون بحكي في حال الفوز
عنده حلول قان ونيه بتسمح له انه ما
تخلينا نوصل لمرحله بقدر اكمل اصير رئيس
او ما اكمل اصير رئيس يعني مو معقول يعني
احنا امامنا محاكمه دراميه وامامنا بعدين
كل الخيارات اللي ممكن تمشي فيها القصه
اكثر دراميه كمان في هذا الموضوع على
العموم نحن بنشكرك على هذه التوضيحات كان
معنا من عمان المحامي المزاول في نيويورك
محمد تيسير النعيمي شكرا لك
في فيديو كان متداول من يومين لموقف يمكن
يكون لاول مره بيتعرض له النجم كره القدم
اللاعب الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي وهذا
الموقف صار معه وهو رايح يلعب مباراه وديه
مع منتخب بلاده ضد استراليا او المباراه
كانت في الصين والموقف المحرج صار له لما
وصل مطار بكيني
الفيديو اللي شفتوه الماسي وهو واقف في
المطار بكين او بالاصح وهو متوقف في
المطار بسبب استخدامه جواز سفره الاسباني
بدل من الارجنتيني وكان مثل ما شفتوا ماسك
جوازه بيتناقش مع ضباط الشرطه في المطار
وتاخر ساعتين الى ان طلع من المطار وقيل
انه سبب التوقيف مشاكل في الجواز
والتاشيره شويه وضحت الصوره مسيك الرايح
بجوازه الاسباني اللي بيسمح له بالسفر
لتايوان من دون تاشيره مس افترض انه اذا
يدخل تايوان بدون تاشيره يعني الصين كمان
نفس الوضع لكن تايوان يعني الدوله يعني
مستقله معترفه فيها دول في العالم والصين
بتعتبرها اقليم مستقل عنها وفي كل الاحوال
شؤونها الخارجيه والتاشيراتها لا علاقه
بالصين والغريب كمان انه ميسي رايح بجوز
الاسباني يلعب مباراه مع منتخب بلاده
الارجنتيني يعني عموما بعد ما وقفوا ساعات
منح التاشيره ودخل الصين
[موسيقى]
اخبار جديده اليوم حقيقه الصادمه بخصوص
قرش الغردقه اللي هاجمت الشاب الروسي
وانهت حياته من اسبوع تقريبا احنا تكلمنا
عن تطورات القضيه اول باول من وقت اصطياد
او
السمكه لتقرير وزاره البيئه او امس كنا
كمان تناولنا البدء بعمليه تحنيطها ووزاره
البيئه معانا اكدت بشكل قاطع انه هذه
السمكه ما سبقت وهاجمت اي بشر ثانيا اليوم
في عالم روسي ومؤسس ورئيس تنفيذي لشركه
تدريب على الغوص في البحر الاحمر طلع
اليوم هذا العالم وقال انه القرش نفسه هذا
قتل سائحين العام الماضي الحادثه الاولى
صارت يوليو وقت هاجم سائحه نمساويه عمرها
68 كانت بتمارس الغطس والثاني سائح روماني
اكلوا القرش حيا على بعد 650 قدم عن
الشاطئ وقال انه بكل حادثتين كان سمكه
القرش حامل ما بتقدر تطارد الاسماك عشان
تاكلها فاكلت بني ادمين انه هذه المره
كمان كانت حامل وراحت على نفس المكان اللي
حصلت فيه او لقت فيه فريسه سهله وكان
ضحيتها الثالثه والاخيره هذا
الشاب الروسي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم بكره الخميس
بكره الخميس الونيس اجمل ايام الاسبوع غدا
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]